ومتابعه لاتمام هذه الصفقه الكبرى
التاريخيه معنا هنا في الاستوديو زميل
محمد القناص مذيع العربيه مذيع الرياضه في
العربيه ومذيعه العربيه للرياضه ههه اهلا
وسهلا محمد همم في تفاصيل همم عن العقد
وتفاصيل العقد كامله لم تعلم حتى الان
التفصيل الوحيد الموجوده عندنا انه اقضي
امتدي لموسمين ونصف ينتهي في صيف 2025
ليمثل بموجب نادي النصر السعودي فقط هذه
التفصيل الوحيد اللي موجود عند الجميع
يعني تحبك حتى الان يعني وسيتم اعلان في
وقت لاحق سواء عن طريق النادي او حتى عن
طريق الممثله اللاعب همم شو يعني لك رياضي
وكان سعودي وعربي وانضمام كريستيانو
رونالدو رياضي بهذا الحجم الى نادي النصر
اكيد انه صفقه كبيره جدا على المستوى
الرياضي في كره القدم في السعوديه واحد من
اهم وابرز واكثر اللاعبين متابعه على
مستوى تاريخ اللعبه في همم في التاريخ
يعني يكون موجود في السعوديه هام جدا وشيء
همم يضيف بشكل جدا يعني لا خلينا ناخذ
بمقاييس اخرى فلتخيل انه مايكل جوردن في
كره السله في عز ايامه في همم في امجاده
ينتقل يلعب مثلا في السعوديه او في مكان
اخر بالتاكيد سيجلب معه جمله كبيره جدا من
المفاهيم التي ستتغير كثير من الامور التي
ستصبح مختلفه النظره العالميه حول كره
القدم السعوديه ستصبح مختلفه وما الى ذلك
من تفصيلات بالتاكيد سيضع حتى تتحدي جديد
امام اللاعبين همم
الاجانب الموجودين في السعوديه اللي
يقدمون نفسهم بشكل افضل حتى يثبته بالفعل
انهم على نفس المستوى اللي موجود همم ياتي
الى السعوديه سيفتح افاق كبرى ايضا لعدد
كبير جدا من النجوم الذي كان يترددون بشكل
او باخر في الذهاب الى السعوديه حتى
باعمار اقل اذا كنت تتكلم عن كريستيانو
رونالدو فانت تتكلم عن احد اهم اللاعبين
بهذا العمر الحالي بنتكلم من 38 سنه
لكن لكن
في نفس الوقت في هناك اسماء كبيره جدا
تتخذ قدوه وبالتالي قد تكون هذه خطوه
تتسرع من قدوم من السعوديه مع مراه اقل
وبالتالي تزيد من همم امكانيه او من قوه
المنافسه في الدوري السعودي
باعتقادك شو النقص اللي راح يغطيه همم
وجود رونالدو
بالتاكيد راح يعطي اضافه كبيره جدا للنصر
على مستوى
التهديف على مستوى
صناعه الفرص وحتى سيكون همم بشكل كبير جدا
مساهم في تحقيق الالقاب تحديدا لقب دوري
ابطال اسيا اللي صعب على الناس في السنوات
الماضيه كامله ممكن يكون واحد من الاسباب
خاصه زي ما عرفنا انه هو الهداف التاريخي
لدوري ابطال اوروبا صاحب خمس بطولات
اوروبيه مع ريال مدريد وبالتالي همم سينقل
هذا الثقافه حتى مع عائلات النصر تبقى
معنا محمد شكرا على هذه المعلومات من دبي
مراد المصري الصحفي الرياضي اهلا بك معنا
يا استاذ مراد ايضا تعليقك الاول على همم
اتمام هذه الصفقه التي سمعنا عنها في
الفتره الاخيره كثيره
مساء الخير عليكم جميعا همم طبعا هاجيء
اعتق
د يعني لا اعتقد ان هناك لاعب بهذا الحجم
همم سبق ان قدم الى المنطقه للاعب ااه حدث
غير عادي اعتقد بغض النظر عن كريستيانو
رونالدو تتحدث على لاعب الاكثر تسجيل
اهداف من اللاعبين الموجودين حاليا اكثر
من 800 هدف في مسيرته الالقاب حتى القيمه
التسويقيه والترويجيه التي ستضاف ليس فقط
والدوري السعودي ولكن حتى السعوديه تستفيد
منه يعني
ابراج المشرق الذي نعرف عن المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تتحدث
اول شخص يتحقق من سمعت مليون متابعه على
انستغرام بالاضافه لمتابعينه بالوسائل
التواصل الاخرى يعني يتكلم عن اعلى
اعلاميه كبيره كريستيانو رونالدو ماركه
همم اعتقد انه وجوده سيكون له همم عوامل
رياضيه ومجتماعيه مهمه للغايه
بحجم كريستيانو رونالدو ينضم الى نادي على
الصعيد السعودي مهم جدا جدا ولكن على
الصعيد العالمي الذي يلعب فيه رونالدو
ربما ليس لديه نفس الحضوه
بالتاكيد هناك مشروع واضح كما ترحه امام
رونالدو
فقط من اجل الكرسي يتحدث انه ممكن الاموال
التي عرضت
اللعب في الفريق ولكن لا اعتقد انه هذا
مجرد الموضوع نتكلم على موضوع الكامل
وواضح تم عرض امام رونالدو كريستيانو
رونالدو
وهو وهو ما جعله بالتاكيد يفكر الموضوع هو
في لقاء صادق قبل كاس العالم اللقاء
الشهير مع مرجان اعترف ان هناك مفاوضات
بناء من السعوديه مع نادي النصر في
البدايه لم يسمى اسم النادي ولكن اعترف ان
هناك مفاوضات وكان نفكر فيها جديه وهو حتى
ما دفعوا الى انهاء عقد مع مانشستر
يونايتد بالتراضي يعني اعتقد انه لاعب
بحجم رونالدو وبالتاريخ وغيرها هو امام
مشروع قادم همم مشروع كبير للغايه همم
تبقى معنا محمد ايضا في يعني استتباعا
لنفس هذه النقطه همم السعوديه في الفتره
الاخيره خاصه تعمل على همم يعني توسيع
نطاق اللعبه وعلى اعلاء شانها وليس فقط من
خلال لاعبين اجانب بمبالغ كبيره همم الى
اي مدى باعتقادك هذا سيشجع اكثر انضمام
لاعبين مثل كريستيانو رونالدو الى نادي
النصر نادي ولا الانديه الاخرى والسعوديه
بشكل عام والمنطقه على العمل على اعلاء
شانه
اللي تكلم عنه الزميل مراد يعني قدوم
كريستيانو وهو بالتاكيد سيكون اضافه كبيره
جدا على المستوى غير حتى الرياضي يتكلم عن
مستوى التسويقي على المستوى الاجتماعي وما
الى ذلك سيساعد في نشر اللعبه بشكل اكبر
حتى داخل المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي
المنطقه بشكل عام وسيرفع التحديات امام
امام اللاعبين السعوديين واللاعبين
الاجانب كما ذكرنا قبل قليل وسيجعل
اللاعبين اللي قلنا عليها قبل شويه انه
اللاعبين همم
والاكبر امكانيات سي يرغبون في القدوم الى
هذه المنطقه واستكشافها بالتاكيد لانه هذا
التحدي الكبير جدا كريستيانو رونالدو واحد
من اهم الاشياء اللي يحب اني اقولها بس
واكد عليها حسب المصادر اللي وصلنا انه
الارقام التي تم تداولها وسائل الاعلام
الغربيه حول الصفقه لم تكن دقيقه العقد
اقل بكثير ما همم تم همم تداول الارقام
حولها هذه الجزئيه الاولى الجزئيه الثانيه
للتاكيد فقط كريستيانو رونالدو دخلوا
الثانويه تجاوز الملياردو دولار وبالتالي
عقده مع مانشستر يونايتد كان 35 مليون
دولار
الاموال التي يجنيها من كره القدم
نفسها ليست الاموال التي تتغير قرار
بالتاكيد هناك امر اخر مشروع كبير جدا
اقتنع فيك كلاعب وهو بحسب لو لم يكن
مقتنعا لما تحدث عن ذلك في فتره سابقه
بانه شاهد مشروع مختلف وممكن ينتقل اليه
وبالتالي هذا سيجعل الجميع الان يبحث ما
هو المشروع الذي سيكون موجود في هذه
البلاد وبالتالي سنذهب للمشاهده عن قرب
كلاعبين كمدربين كحتى خبرات رياضيه مختلفه
نتكلم عن المستوى
دوله كبير ولي العهد السعودي لتطوير رياضه
كره القدم في السعوديه وحتى بقيه الرياضات
بشكل مختلف لينكس بشكل او باخر حتى على
المشروع الكبير الذي يقوله لحد السعوديه
المملكه 2030 في همم السنوات المقبله تمام
همم مراد همم بدات تتضح اذن اكثر فاكثر
معالم وملامح هذا المشروع الاكبر
كما تكلم الجميل يعني ممكن يجب ان نرى كيف
تم بناء ما وصل اليه كرستيانو رونالدو كيف
وصل السعوديه للسنوات السابقه هناك جنود
واضحه من صاحب السمو الامير محمد بن سلمان
قامت ببناء قاعده للدوري يعني الدوري
السعودي اصبح عالمي بمعنى الكلمه في
السنوات الاخيره استقبال اسماء كبيره
منافسه قويه حتى عندما
دوري ابطال اسيا الذي مستمر حاليا نجد
حوالي ثلاث فرق متاهله في الدوري الثاني
يعني حتى قوه فنيه همم هناك قوه تم بناء
قاعده صلبه من ما حد تم استقطاب بعد ذلك
كريستيانو رونالدو انت لا يمكن ان تبني
بدايه رونالدو هناك عمل سنوات الاخيره ادى
الى وجود كريستيانو رونالدو لاكمال هذا
المش
روع وهو ممكن حبه الكرز في المشروع الكبير
الذي يتم بناءه واعتقد انه ما زال هناك
ايضا المزيد حتى عن من شاهد ليس فقط في
كره القدم في العاب رياضيه كثيره كبر
ى في السعوديه هناك مشروع واضح لجعل يعني
الرياضه من الاهداف الاستراتيجيه في
المملكه شكرا جزيلا لك مراد المصري صحفي
الرياضي من دبي شكرا محمد القناص همم
زميلنا مذيع الرياضه في العربيه اليك